hola qué tal muy buen día precisamente
el gobierno lo que quiere evitar es el
colapso de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos de los hospitales la región
más afectada es el norte y ya han tenido
que tomar medidas como por ejemplo
trasladar pacientes desde los hospitales
del norte a hospitales en la capital
precisamente porque no se dan abasto hay
hospitales en el norte que ya superan el
90% de la capacidad en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos y también se han
llevado acuerdos como por ejemplo con
casas de misericordia para ayudar a
aliviar la presión que hay en los
hospitales también esta presión ya se
está sintiendo en lisboa valle de útero
y alentejo que son otras zonas también
afectadas por la pandemia
una decisión que no querían tomar los
médicos pero que ha sido autorizada por
el ministerio de salud ha sido también
suspender todas aquellas cirugías no
urgentes se han suspendido miles de
cirugías en lo que va de año desde que
inició la pandemia desde el mes de marzo
para también dejar disponibles camas a
pacientes que estén dando positivo al
kobe y se hayan complicado con esta
situación es una situación lamentable
para aquellos que necesitan
y otras enfermedades sin embargo es la
decisión que se han tenido que tomar los
médicos para precisamente aliviar la
presión en los hospitales y muy
rápidamente de daniela cómo ha tomado la
población en la aplicación de estas
medidas y cuáles serían las nuevas
medidas que llegarían si se prorroga el
estado de emergencia
en líneas generales la población ha
acatado las medidas restrictivas que
recordemos a partir de las 11 de la
noche se prohíbe la circulación en más
de simples de 190 municipios y los fines
de semana a partir de la una de la tarde
sin embargo sí ha habido rechazo y
protesta por parte de los comerciantes y
los dueños de restaurantes pues han sido
los más afectados económicamente
hablando por estas medidas se espera que
el gobierno evalúa ahora escalones según
el riesgo de municipio y aplicar
distintas medidas para estos municipios
siendo aquellos que tengan más de 960
casos por cada 100.000 habitantes donde
se tomarían más restricciones sin
embargo ya hay partidos que han
adelantado que no van a votar a favor de
que continúa en este confinamiento sobre
todo los fines de semana pues apuestan a
otras medidas esto se va a debatir el
viernes como lo dices en el parlamento y
posteriormente se espera el anuncio del
presidente